we are breaking into programming to go
straight to the UK Supreme Court in
London where judges have just ruled
against Prime Minister Boris Johnson's
decision to suspend Parliament let's
listen to supreme court judge
Brenda Hale the advice was unlawful the
inner house went further and declared
that any prorogation resulting from it
was null and have no effect the
government argues that the inner house
could not do that because the
prorogation was a quote proceeding in
Parliament and quote which under the
Bill of Rights of 1688 cannot be
impugned or questioned in any court but
it is quite clear that the prorogation
is not a proceeding in Parliament it
takes place in the House of Lords
chamber in the presence of members of
both houses but it is not their decision
it is something which has been imposed
upon them from outside it is not
something on which members can speak or
vote it is not the core or essential
business of Parliament which the Bill of
Rights protects quite the reverse it
brings that core or essential business
to an end this Court has already
concluded that the Prime Minister's
advice to Her Majesty was unlawful void
and have no effect
this means that the order in Council to
which it led was also unlawful void and
of no effect and should be quashed this
means that when the Royal Commissioners
walked into the House of Lords it was as
if they had walked in with a blank sheet
of paper
the prorogation was also void and of no
effect Parliament has not been probed
this is the unanimous judgment of all
eleven justices it is for Parliament and
in particular speaker and the Lord
speaker to decide what to do next unless
there is some parliamentary rule of
which we are unaware they can take
immediate steps to enable each house to
meet
as soon as possible it is not clear to
us that any step is needed from the
prime minister but if it is the court is
pleased that his counsel have told the
court that he will take all necessary
steps to comply with the terms of any
declaration made by this court it
follows that the Advocate General's
appeal in the case of cherry is
dismissed and mrs. Miller's appeal is
allowed the same declarations and orders
should be made in each case copies of
our full judgement explaining these
conclusions and a transcript of this
summary will be available immediately
after the court rises and I urge you all
to read them with care the court will
now adjourn you are looking at live
pictures from the UK Supreme Court the
highest court in the United Kingdom
where the court has ruled on the
legality of Johnson as five week
suspension of Parliament ruling that it
was unlawful well let's bring in our
correspondent Rory challon's who's
outside the Supreme Court in London Rory
a damming ruling there by the UK's
highest court clearly this is going to
be a huge blow for the British
government and for Prime Minister Boris
Johnson where can he go from here
this is as you say a deep blow heavy
blow for Boris Johnson and his
Parliament the ruling given by the
Supreme Court on the three questions
that it was considering was unanimous
all eleven justices essentially ruled
against the government on this they were
being asked was this matter justice able
is it a thing that the court should have
decided on Rob being just a political
matter that Boris Johnson as the Prime
Minister had every right to do except
for a rogue Parliament well the supreme
justice you can hear some groups of
celebration there from campaigners who
say placards saying don't silence MPs
over there they are very pleased with
this decision
so yes the the Supreme Court said that
this was a Justice of all matter it was
an issue for the courts not just for
Boris Johnson and his rise as prime
minister they also decided that this was
not a routine prorogation a routine
suspension of Parliament as the
government has argued all along it's
basically been saying that this was the
longest parliamentary session in modern
times and therefore it was totally
normal for a new prime minister to be
able to suspend Parliament for a few
weeks and come up with a new platform
legislation the Supreme Court has said
no this clearly was not normal not
routine this was something that was done
at a critical points in parliamentary
activity when serious matters were being
debated by the houses of parliament and
therefore it was denying the houses of
parliament the ability to do its duty
then the most serious question of all
was this lawful deeds Boris Johnson have
the right to do this was he acting
lawfully and unanimously these justices
all decided that no he wasn't so
effectively the suspension of Parliament
is void it has no effect that's what
lady Hale was saying there it now is up
to the speakers of the houses of
there has a Commons and the House of
Lords to work out what happens next but
effectively this means that as she just
said Parliament's is still in session
and its people at any and Boris Johnson
has said that he will respect whatever
the court decides the ball is in his
court now
it absolutely certainly is it was quite
a damning statement that Supreme Court
Judge Brenda Hale said saying that
Parliament has not been probed basically
saying that the strategy as boyce
johnson's rivals claim he has
implemented here was really to make sure
that MPs were out of the way to push
forward with the possibility of a No
Deal brexit this will come as a very
positive move of course - Boyce
Johnson's rivals know devastating just
just gonna jump in there Rory because
some key figures have come outside the
Supreme Court on our speaking now to the
media from the last few weeks have seen
an extraordinary series of attacks on
our democracy a parliament elected from
46 million of us was unlawfully
suspended by prime minister elected from
160,000 judges have been threatened by a
number 10 source and those of us who
have sought to protect the only
institution in our Constitution with a
uk-wide Democratic mandate have been
subject to death threats and some of us
have had our home addresses published I
am delighted today that the Supreme
Court has protected the foundational
principle of any democracy which is the
right of members of parliament to do
their jobs for which they were elected
there is much yet to be done to protect
our democracy for myself I am very
grateful to the exceptional legal team
and to the almost 8,000 small donors who
enabled this case to go ahead the
victory is theirs